bonsoir à tous l'un est à la recherche
de sa mère qui l'a abandonné
l'autre d'un bandit qui a enlevé son
enfant celui ci d'une belle inconnue
dont il est tombé éperdument amoureux
dès le premier regard et enfin celui là
est parti sur les traces de rimbaud vrai
zoo imaginaire autant de recherche
enquête et filatures
où
dessins tirés de cette bande dessinée
parue chez dargaud
une aventure de cliff burton brouillard
sur whitehall les l'histoire et de
rodolphe et dessins de garcia lors c'est
évidemment c'est une enquête du yard
comme on dit tu penses que tu en gardes
quand on est branché on dit de garde
voilà je lis bande dessinée alors je
vous présenter mes quatre invités en
commençant par frédéric dard dit san
antonio dans la série de ce qu'on
appelle vos récits psychologique noir
orné de faire paraître aux éditions
fleuve noir
faut-il tuer les petits garçons qui ont
les mains sur les hanches
alors c'est ça récit d'un enlèvement qui
paraît un an et demi après un kidnapping
tout à fait vrai celui ci le graphique
de votre fille joséphine il ya donc un
an et demi et nous verrons tout à
l'heure comment la la réalité a fait
irruption dans la fiction à côté de vous
alain borer vous êtes poète vous êtes
professeur de culture générale aux
beaux-arts de tours et vous êtes un
passionné extraordinaire pour l'oeuvre
et la vie de rimbaud vous avez réalisé
d'ailleurs un film en ethiopie intitulé
le voleur de feu qui a été diffusée par
tf1 et vous nous proposer ce soir deux
ouvrages consacrés à rimbaud rimbaud en
abyssinie aux éditions du seuil et un
sur rimbaud cns se disant négociants qui
est publié aux éditions lachenal
héritèrent henri vincenot henri vincenot
dont le dernier roman paraît aux
éditions denoël sous le titre l'oeuvre
de chair et qui est un livre tout entier
à la gloire non pas de la bourgogne
comme on pourrait s'y attendre de
l'automobile bobos mais de la bretagne
voilà qui va en surprendre plus d'un et
puis enfin michel del castillo romancier
prix des libraires prix renaudot vous et
j'ai failli obtenir le grand prix du
roman de l'académie française et je veux
dire vous l'auriez bien mérité pour ce
roman intitulé la gloire de dina qui
paraît aux éditions du seuil
jeudi au départ c'est un roman à la fois
très romanesque et et bouleversant mais
on verra pourquoi tout alors pourquoi il
est bouleversant vrai d'abord qu'on
parle du romanesque
alors le ce n'est pas le début du livre
mais j'aimerais que vous commenciez par
la peau foncée la chronologie
on est par ces temps ci ciblent tout
tout tout juste avant la dernière guerre
il y a un enfant une fois une mère c'est
bien s'appelle dinas et d'héroïne
vivre et elle est maire sublime oui pour
tous les cas pour le propos le petit
garçon qu'il allait sublime il vit à la
fois entre sa grand'mère assunta qu'on
appelle à soupe auparavant bréger sa
mère d'hinnin et puis de deux
domestiques dont une sorte une attaque y
tient peu le vieux balai en charge parce
que la famille un petit peu perdu de ses
anciens moyens et c'est vrai que ce
garçon est à la fois ébloui fasciné et
amoureux de cette mère qui lui
appartient tout entière puisqu'il ya pas
de pair dans la maison elle a été mariée
l'inde ni frère mais qui vient les
jeudis très bien élevé très bon chic bon
genre comment il ya aujourd'hui mais qui
pour lui n'est pas un rival parce qu'il
est trop grand et vient deux fois par
semaine donc sa mère c'est à lui son
père est français il ce qu'ils ont fait
il sait que son père est français il n'a
jamais vu en tous les cas ils en gardent
pas de souvenirs et puis bon il vit
c'est vrai dans une intimité très
profonde et très charnelle mais max est
maire c'est le bonheur c'est le bonheur
c'est le bonheur et puis alors le
malheur arrive
parce que la femme la mère est obligé de
s'exiler parce qu'elle fascisme et quel
est son amant est un républicain il
défend la république petits fascistes
donc qu'elle est obligée de venir en
france
et puis c'est la guerre en france elle
est à marseille
et là c'est la catastrophe ben oui c'est
la catastrophe d'abord pour elle parce
que c'est une femme qui a été habitué à
l'argent qui est habituel certains une
facilité de vie qui d'un seul coup se
retrouve sans argent sans emploi sans
quart de travail sans papiers à une
époque un petit peu qu'ils n'ont cours
d'hôtels un hôtel avec cet enfant mais
avec aussi des habitudes qu'elle avait
du temps c'est à dire qu'elle est à la
fois d'un seul coup complètement folle
et prodigue dépensant c'est le peu
d'argent qui lui il reste le flambant
littéralement souper et puis un seul
coup tu l'attends sol où elle perd petit
à petit ses moyens et c'est vrai que le
gosse un petit à petit qui commence à
devenir une charge que elle va entre
guillemets essayer de la frêle va
l'abandonner
oui enfin dans tous les cas le laissera
elle va laisser elle va laisser tout
seul et c'est vrai que pour ce gamin qui
a vécu neuf ans d'une intimité de total
avec une telle mère dont il est
littéralement amoureux sens fort du
terme c'est la seul coup la chute d'un
enfer alors l'enfant survit à la guerre
on va pas dire comment on va faire un
peu importe et puis après la guerre mais
la mère ne réapparaît pas dinars est
restée à l'enfant la la croit morte et
l'enfant a grandi il a fait ses études
et devient et crimes
lien un écrivain il va publier son lit
publie son premier roman
et puis un jour il fait une lecture
alors ses skis oui alors ça je vous
dirais bombe à ccc le détails
biographiques de cette es parti pour
écrire ce livre je sortais de 40 ans sur
telle époque de l'hôpital est une
maladie assez grave et j'avais failli
mourir et puis j'avais difficultés
financières comme il arrive aux écrits
assez souvent dans ces câlins et j'avais
accepté une chronique radiophonique
littéraire sur un jour en choisissant
roman d'un seul coup en lisant petit à
petit je me suis aperçu qu'il s'agissait
de mon débit frères dont j'avais
vaguement entendu parler qui avait été
abandonné à deux ans lui alors enfin le
place et placés chez des gens et donc
j'ai poursuivi cette lecture d'une façon
absolument halluciné parce que d'abord
je le connaissais pas j'en avais
vaguement entendu parler et lui
n'avaient jamais connu sa mère au fond
j'écris un peu le livre il est mort
maintenant mais j'ai pu écrire un peu le
livre pour lui rendre la mémoire qui n'a
pas voulu rendre la mère qui n'a pas eu
un petit peu par delà comme une espèce
de à la fois dommage à elle est dommage
à lui si vous voulez cesser c'est de là
que c'est parti moi même j'avais
retrouvé à l'époque mais oui mais reste
étonnant parce que vous publiez à faire
l'autre le narrateur publie un livre
c'est un éditeur il découvre quelques
mois après publié par le même éditeur un
livre et s'aperçoit qu'il un demi frère
alors ce demi frère d'ailleurs est un
peu mythomane il a du talent il est
pianiste mais c'est finalement petit
escroc
et c'est écouter oui mais ce qui m'a
bien plus il ya beaucoup de points
communs j'en parlais tout à l'heure avec
avec l'histoire frédéric dard qui m'ont
beaucoup troublé mais ce qui m'avait
vraiment les siens à lucie l'époque
c'est d'abord que des mots viennent sur
des mots se taire que je le retrouve par
lille ça ça me paraissait hallucinant
sur les pages qu'il y aurait mille
moyens mais pas celui et puis ensuite
que quand je me suis aperçu que j'ai
commencé à interroger
nous étions croisés sans arrêt il allait
chercher julliard quand j allais il
connaissait christian bourrel
connaissait marcel jullian il
connaissait plein de gens que j'avais
connu qu'il avait connu qu'il avait
entendu jouer du piano qu'il avait dès
qu'il avait dépanné qui était allé le
voir quand ils allaient de prise en
prison et aux fournisseurs qui ont eu
mille fois l'occasion de nous rencontrer
mais comme ils portaient un autre nom
puisque c'est par l'impact de leur
connaît moi je n'avais jamais ses liens
et lui encore moins si bien que le fonds
mondial en ce moment là dans le doubs
cas dans leur monde
le sandre on retrouve sa mère dina
oui là il a retrouvé la retrouve tout à
fait par hasard à paris elle s'est
remariée à paris elle vit effectivement
ils se retrouvent commence alors une
autre histoire entre mais c'est une
autre femme qu'il retrouve met une autre
femme oui mais c'est une femme qui ne
reconnaît pas qu'elle a eue c'est une
autre femme et c'est le temps passé
oui je crois pas que je crois que la
mère que sandro et menez est une mère de
rêve il ne voyait pas à l'enfant de 8
ans ne doit pas sa mère
il voit mitsou les moins je sais pas
mais si j'appelle avait propres
souvenirs dit n'allez pas tout à fait un
maire d'abord ma mère n'était pas
cécilienne ovules pas comme ça mais vous
écoutez là michel ganivet je vous arrête
quand même connais un petit peu votre
vie parce que vous l'avez abordé dans le
présent roman et quand on lit ce livre
vraiment attentivement comme je lé fais
on s'aperçoit que c'est une
transposition italienne de votre
aventure espagnole
oui il ya et c'est vrai qu'il y à
beaucoup rassoul et je crois que j'ai
mis même inconsciemment je vous dis
encore une fois comme l'espèce
d'exorcisme général ce qu'il y avait
mais j'avais bien conscience que c'est
un personnage rêver je veux dire plus
incapable de dire s'il était comme ça la
réalité que ce que je voyais huit ans la
robe du soir le manteau de fourrure le
parfum une espèce de beauté un peu
mythique si vous voulez le nuage
connaissent une belle femme quand elle
paraît que revient mais dans la trace
d'un enfant je l'entends avait d'abord
donné par
mais oui avec abandonné laissé tout seul
parce que je voulais que je regagne
l'espagne et que je retrouve ma grande
mais je trouve que maintenant je pars
gagner l'espagne et que j'ai dû faire un
détour ailleurs mais bon je crois que il
faut bien se rendre compte c'est que les
terrorise ya l'époque il était
pourchassé qu'un enfant lui poser
beaucoup à c'était une femme mêmes qui
risquait sa peau tous les jours et là
vraiment cru bien faire en dix ans il va
retourner en espagne chez ma mère voilà
bon ça a été ça saute
malheureusement ça n'a pas marché comme
ça pour elle et comment la manière dont
vous l'avez retrouvé après la guerre
c'est aussi ce qui dans le roman
oui j'ai retrouvé tout à fait pas tout à
fait pas comme ça oui tout à fait et
quand elle vous a revu après quinze
années d'absence
elle vous a dit tiens tu dois faire du
cinéma oui c'était le premier mot
trébouta faire du cinéma
oui c'est pour ça que je crois que
vraiment vous cernez de très très près
oui il ya des chose de vraiment de squat
mais c'est ça qui est émouvant c'est
parce qu'on vous avez raconté un petit
peu tout ça dans le précédent roman
seigle et les rapports presque
désespérée que vous avez eue avec votre
mère alors là il cette fois on peut dire
que vous racontez pratiquement votre vie
il vous racontera l'itinéraire
absolument l'itinéraire bis mais aussi à
cause de la présence ou les deux de ceux
morts qui me hantaient sous le ster que
j'étais tout le temps tu es par l'idée
de quelqu'un qui ne l'avait pas vu dans
son temps de fin de ce que j'appelle
vouloir de façon ironique mais qui qui
n'allait jamais eu lui donne l'air et
que je voulais lui rendre un peu c'est
tenir là mais qu'est ce qui fait que lui
donc votre demi frère a mal tourné alors
que vous avez vous avez réussi
écoutez moi je crois pas qu'il y ait des
explications techologique total mayhem
chose qui me paraît moins évident c'est
au moins jusqu'à l'âge de 9 ans moi
j'étais mais j'existe et voilà et lui il
n'a pas eu un mot maintenant il n'y a eu
personne et il s'est inventé des mythes
il a été obligé de s'inventer des
parents mythique ne sais pas qui c'est
et il a commencé à se mentir pour
survivre dans ce cas que la fabulation
pour lui c'est d'ailleurs après il n'a
même pas pu aboutir à la littérature
sont fort qui n'est pas la mémoire et la
littérature seul à bord de la mémoire
profonde je crois vous aviez c'est vrai
au départ ce qu'ils n'avaient pas un
capital de tendre est absolue
absolument j'avais encore investi soul
et j'avais des souvenirs de gloire des
souvenirs d'amours et si vous voulez bon
moi j'étais quelqu'un qui se remettait
très mal de ce qui m'était arrivé mais
j'avais une mémoire il n'a jamais et
dont il a été laissé à deux ans et il
n'a jamais vu ses parents donc que vous
voulez il n'a pu que les inventer que
les bus et tout récemment il ya quelques
jours le hasard a fait que j'étais donc
dans la région où il a vécu et que des
libraires qui l'ont très bien connu mal
on parle et les mises et c'était
pathétique parce qu'il a toute sa vie
parler de ses parents en ce moment donc
il s'était qui est l'été comme en vtt
possible toute cette histoire oui mais
il a revu sa mère très très oui mais là
vu une femme déjà j'ai très très âgés
que j'avais d'ailleurs beaucoup hésité à
lui rendre si vous voulez parce que je
me disais comment ça va se passer entre
tout simplement soul était de rendre à
quelqu'un qui à près de 50 ans une mère
qui la laisse est tout petit et qu'il va
devoir affronter ses pas vides au gg
c'est pour ça que je lui ai laissé le
choix reluisant douala livre fait ce que
tu prévois faire et la ville elle a été
très bien avec lui à ce personnage de la
mère est tout de même assez terrifiant
parce que au début de votre livre on se
dit qu elle
quelle chance il a ce genre d'avoir une
mère aussi belle aussi
si attentive aussi tendre qui après
cette mère dont on s'aperçoit qu'elle a
quasiment abandonné tous ses enfants
mais elle a été pris dans un piège il
faut bien dire pointe il a été marié
presque contre son gré à 16 ans et vous
écoute là j'imagine tout à fait elle a
donc été marié pratiquement de force la
saison et elle s'est très vite elle est
retourné à ses premières amours avec
quelqu'un et les deux enfants qu'elle a
eus avec l'état à l'époque une femme ne
pouvait ni les reconnaître foulée la
situation d'adultère notamment dans les
pays du sud et hector elles étaient
passibles de prison
si bien que quand même il aurait voulu
le reconnaître il ne pouvait pas le
faire alors je crois que le père a donné
le nom d'un des ses domestiques
au fait ils étaient deux frères
s'aperçoit quand on fait le compte c'est
qu'on s'aperçoit que cette femme a eu
six enfants
arsène complètement la réalité je veux
dire c'est effectivement parce que
michel del castillo sait que sa mère les
côtes là c'est évident donc je pense qu
il a une pudeur c'est tellement grossier
mais c'est vrai que ça quand on a lu
tous les deux michel casting tout ça se
rejoint
la seule chose qui est passé ce qu'il a
fait pendant la guerre mais ça vous
l'avez raconter ses dents tanguy bon
mais moi ce qui m'a frappé là dedans
c'est ce désespoir plein de dignité ça
je vous admire beaucoup parce que je
sais être désespéré ça m'arrive mais je
sais pas à monter autant de dignité est
resté secret comme vous raconter ça à
pas feutrés si josi à plumes feutrée et
je trouve que c'est ce qui fait la
qualité essentielle de votre livre
qu'est ce qui vous a sauvé vous c'est
l'écriture absolument moi ça a été non
seulement la mi mai la littérature en
général enfin je n'avais pas découvert
la littérature mais ça aussi il faut
suivre et c'est pour ça que j'essaye
toujours de nuit ainsi un peu chaud
c'est le plus magnifique présent qu'elle
mais c'est la littérature s'attelle
toute la petite enfance c'est elle qui
m'a donné a été un tueur c'est elle qui
m'a donné la musique c'est elle qui m'a
donné l'art donc si vous voulez moi
j'étais un enfant archicomble et gela
l'agenais l'essentiel l'essentiel
elle m'a donné vraiment les chantiers et
il m'a donné une foule des moyens de
survie et je dirais même un peu
cruellement
elle m'a même donné en me les champs la
chance de me retrouver je crois que si
nous si ça va continuer je serai très
mal fini parce que c'était une femme qui
a une très forte personnalité et je m'en
serais très mal sorti donc alain sens
maintenant je suis très content depuis
l'âge de 9 ans d'avoir été obligé de
vivre ce wee b aujourd'hui parce que
vous êtes à plaisir et vous noyez
certainement pas dit ça il ya 15 ans 20
ans je l'aurais pas 10 à 17 ans à ses 11
saisons à 20 ans des mains de gens j'ai
commencé à dire ça vers 35 40 ans et
j'ai surtout commencer à dire st quand
j'ai ri quand j'ai découvert l'existence
de céder mes frères maison parce qu'il
était mon négatif me suis dit voilà ce
que j'aurais pu devenir voulez ça aurait
pu être sympa c'est votre double
nocturne absolument c'est un peu mon
propre échec même à l'écriture je veux
dire mais même en tant qu'écrivain c'est
vrai qu'il n'a pas pu même faire une
carrière d'écrivain tellement il était
minée par personne
ce quelqu'un qui n'arrivait pas tout
simplement mais il avait quand même un
charme inouï parce qu'il savait menti
c'était un séducteur assez étonnante
approché m'ont dit qu'ils étaient la
séduction des mais il était très bon
pianiste papa le dire tout ce qu'il
disait
parce qu'il a raconté beaucoup de trac
sénat il était beau l'écrivain g lui les
trois romans qui l'a publié c'est de la
bonne littérature un peu de ses six un
peu lyrique un peu comme il devait
l'être lui-même ce que j'appelle moi le
le côté pythie je crois qu'il partait
très vite dans un lyrisme excessif mal
maîtrisée mais c'est technique manifeste
de man forte personnalité est quoi
mais pour un peu de côté quand même une
scène terrifiante par exemple contre
votre mère le retrouve et bien l essec
de le monter contre vous elle dit c'est
toi quel talent c'est pas l'autre mais
je crois que ça l est et où j'allais je
me suis posé très souvent cette question
je ne sais pas très bien ce qu'ils ont
pu se dire mais je me dis une femme qui
n'a pas vu son fils pendant quarante et
quelques années qu'elle allait c'est
donc à deux ans qu'elle a confié c'est
quelqu'un qui se trouve à ça suffit ou
bien ils se mentent ou bien ne peut rien
se dit le pascaa rien à dire qu'est ce
que voulait dire de 40 ans de silence ou
bien vous étriper ou bien vous dit rien
ou bien vous mentez je crois qu'ils se
sont montés un peu mes vingt premiers on
vous a parlé de cette rencontre
l'e-book jamais abordé le sujet avec lui
tout à fait tout à fait tout à fait
parce que je crois que c'était
probablement que c'est quelque chose
dont elle a beaucoup souffert
intérieurement et même de tout ça je
crois qu'elle on ne sait souvent pas
dans la vie commence à rire ces choses
est à la fois les pièges sociaux les
pièges de la guerre les choses qui
arrivent qui font que c'est très
difficile
le vrai en question qui écrit également
un roman michel del castillo dit qu'il
est lui-même schizophrène d'une certaine
façon comme si tout était à nouveau
coupée en deux alors ce silence auquel
on atteint alors même qu'on pourrait
entendre la fameuse petite musique de
l'écrivain et l'est dans le dans le
livre de michel del castillo et alors
même que dina et en somme une cantatrice
glissé du talent même s'il termine dans
les estaminets d'un seul coup l'opéra
cesse et on est devant cette sorte de
vérité qui n'est pas une vérité sereine
comme serait le succès que représente
michel del castillo par rapport à son
double malheureux c'est la difficulté
d'être soi vu la différence entre la
filature et la recherche c'est
évidemment que la filature on cherche
quelqu'un qui nous mène vers quelque
chose de précis et que par conséquent le
but est déjà donné or dans la recherche
le but n'est pas donné il ne peut il
peut même peut-être ne l'être jamais et
c'est ça qui fait que au fond
ils n'y arrivent tout cas ce que vient
de dire je trouve son titre encore plus
magistrale et bloc 10,2 cette dame qui
nous écoutent peut-être en ce moment en
fait qui orienteront suis je touche
enfin cet hommage est terriblement
émouvant alors vous donnez furtivement
ces pages 38 la raison pour laquelle
vous avez mis finalement pas mal
d'années écrire ce livre parce que vous
avez tourné autour beaucoup et
finalement c'est dur de les cuire comme
cela vous le dit et il faudrait dire
celui les profanes s'imagine qu écrire
et dire exprime une activité identique
on sourit pas gelée soulignait aussi on
se mettrait écrire parce qu'on a quelque
chose à dire
rien n'est plus faux il arriver plus
souvent qu'on ne le pense qu'il faille
des années un écrivain pour entrevoir ce
qu'ils aspirent à dire
et s'il le dit c'est plus souvent encore
à son insu car l'écrivain habite le
silence oui mais ça ça je de cette
filiale à peu près exactement la même
phrase et face aux daims dans le livre
de bresse au baroque parce que je crois
effectivement qu'il ya un moment donné
où le langage de bouchra vertige de
silence où vous les gars quelque chose
ce n'est pas comme on veut dire les mots
se mange dans un film qui n'est pas fils
ans à dire c'est pas ça c'est une autre
une autre notre silence comme une espèce
de mur de son on a deux noms soient bien
merci michel del castillo alors passé à
san antonio
alors voilà en mars mars 83 tous les
gens qui nous écoutent le rappelle
certainement un public non quand même un
jour de mars 83 tous les journaux les
gros titres des journaux c'était aussi
la fille de frédéric dard alias antonio
joséphine a été enlevé vous avez versé
là
la rançon c'était deux millions de
francs suisses 2 millions de francs
suisses qui fait des vrais france des
vêtements ça fait combien ça 2 millions
de francs suisses a fait 800 millions
maintenant 800 millions de centimes
tiens on parle de sentiments comme en
suisse pour qu'on nous parle des
français dont vous voulez nous humilier
bon alors donc lave la rançon à verser
puis joséphine est relâché c'est le
pardon de vous interromps mais je vais
dire que ce raccourci quand je l'entends
maintenant la petite est kidnappé la
rançon versée si vous saviez bien sûr
dans l'intervalle ce qui s'est passé en
procès
mais je suis obligé de rappeler que je
sais que tu repars donc eva lyon et donc
la police suisse fait très bien son
travail elle une relation au grand prix
de la peur elle leur trou il a été jugé
il ya quelques jours ya trois semaines
il a été condamné à 18 ans de 18 ans de
réclusion 18 ans de réclusion
voilà or il se trouve que ce jour de
mars
83 le jour où votre fille joséphine est
enlevé et bien vous étiez en train
d'écrire un livre dont vous aviez écrit
132 pages des 132 premières pages de ce
livre
alors je voudrais que vous me disiez
comme ça en quelques mots quel est le
contenu des 132 et bien écoutez depuis
plusieurs années déjà j'avais conçu le
sujet suivant un romancier habitants
gstaad
c'est à dire personnage qui me
ressemblent mais qui n'est pas moi
romancier comme ça que je sais que
j'avais inventé
marié à une femme ayant un enfant de
d'une première d'un premier mariage
n'aime pas cet enfant il aime passer
tant parce qu'il a épousé la femme et il
n'a pas épousé l'enfant est alors l
lagacé le trouble sa vie à elle elle vit
quand même à l'écart de ce couple elle
est en pension dans un village même de
gstaad mais il veut pas l'avoir été au
du couple d'enfer et un été ailleurs du
coup c'est l'enfer la femme boit il ya
quelque chose de détruit là dedans et
puis un jour on kidnappe des malfrats
croyant que c'est vraiment sa fille
kidnappée l'enfant et demande rançon oui
alors attendez oui un peu moins vite
c'est à dire que vous racontez très bien
écouter parce que vous vous avez vu huit
commandements oui mais là oui mais match
aller lentement
parce que c'est la fiction qui m
intéresse finalement oui puisque
l'arrière laisser le roman donc il y à
un comédien comme ça que thomas bon bah
si on raconte simplement fait pas ce que
vous racontez premier c'est que vous
montrer très bien le nom c'est dans les
cent trente deux premières pages
m'adresse beaucoup c'est à ce comédien
comme ça qu'ils étaient en train de
fomenter son coup et puis donc ils
enlèvent doral s'appelle d'orage
je crois bien ainsi lorsque la mer est
un moyen détail quand même votre votre
écrivain s'appelle charles ii jallieu
oui
or vous êtes né à bourgoin jallieu oui
je suis né à jallieu je suis né à chaque
but quand même charles de jamioulx non
j'ai pas curieux enfin écouter juste
après ça on doit dire que maintenant je
veux dire que toute ma carrière a été
basée sur le délire d'imagination
vraiment j'ai de l'imagination entend
faire comme je sais plus quand vous de
la mettant des livres et tout va bien
merci
mais pour une fois j'ai voulu
m'impliquer
c'est à dire que dans mon esprit j'ai
inventé un personnage qui n'était pas
tout à fait moi mais qui vivait comme
moi qui avait quand même des tic au
point si vous voulez quelque part bien
sûr que je m'identifie à lui par la
force des choses puisque j'avais envie
moi de m'exprimer de m'exprimer mais
j'avais pensé à la chose suivante c'est
que ce romancier écrivait on le prend il
est temps à nigré une histoire et cette
histoire c'est celle de ma propre vie
c'est à dire qui raconte l'histoire d'un
petit garçon un kaki et mal foutu qui a
un problème et par flash et il balance
la vie de ce petit garçon que la mienne
qu'il est la couverture de duke et cette
photo qui se sait une photo de moi c'est
une photo de ses photos de oui j'avais
quatre ans là dessus le pire dans le
monde soit derrière nous et c'est votre
mère c'est ma mère et le chat c'est un
passeur face à se classer dans l'ardèche
donc on traversait à l'époque l'euro
n'avait qu'un bac à traille et c'était
le passeur ça bon alors alors il y alors
d'un seul coup irruption de la réalité
de notre fiction alors irruption de la
réalité c'est à dire que je venais de
dycker l'enlèvement par ce comédien raté
sur un gars pour ce port se procurer du
fric
et kidnappe la suite du romancier enfin
la belle-fille du romancier
et puis il s'est passé cette chose et
bah aberrante c'est que un matin le
lendemain matin du jour j'ai écrit ça ma
femme est venue m'appeler enfin
peut-être pas exactement le lendemain
matin elle m'appelle en faisais ce que
je sais fine est avec toi parce que je
me lève tous le matin que je prépare le
déjeuner tout le monde avant que le
personnel soit levé et il me dit
joséphine est pas dans sa chambre et
tout a commencé comme ça l'horreur est
entré dans la maison et l'aurore est
entré dans la fiction l'horreur est
entré dans la fiction est entré dans la
maison et alors il ya une espèce de
télescopage du réel et de l'irréel qui
est absolument forcené et je vais vous
dire une chose quand on a retrouvé
joséphine voyez je réside quand on a eut
retrouvé joséphine j'avais mon manuscrit
bien sûr en coups et pendant le rapt
pendant ces heures affreuse au cours
desquelles on est assis ma femme et moi
dans un fauteuil entouré de policiers
bienveillant fraternelle et je leur dis
un grand coup de chapeau depuis la
france aujourd'hui je tiens à les
remercier on peut lancer des messages
personnels alors je le fais est bien
entouré de ses policiers nous de prostré
ma femme ça c'est une espèce de femmes
qui avaient vieilli des descentes
enrayée et brusquement
qu'est ce que je disais non mais
simplement je n'ai pas voulu raconter
qu'ils avaient ce manuscrit
je pense que oui alors brusquement ya ce
médian son concours aux troupes non
parce que j'étais parti en dérapage
incontrôlé
on retrouve joséphine et j'avais un ami
à la maison qui nous a prodigieusement
secondes et qui est directeur de la tv
en suisse champ du mur je lui dis bien
dans mon bureau vient dans mon bureau
tu va m'accorder un quart d'heure je
veux te montrer quelque chose et je lui
ai fait lire sur manuscrit la rapt de
l'histoire du rap parce que je lui ai
dit je sais que si je termine ce livre
est le jour où il sera publié
on croira jamais on pensa que je me suis
inspiré de cette histoire pour faire ce
roman et je veux que quelqu'un en dehors
de ma femme puisse porter témoignage que
j'avais écrit ça avant le bon alors ce
qui est alors après vous donc le même ce
crime dans un placard
après il ya un sentiment de rejet il ya
celle
dépôt vente a l'impression qu'on a
déclenché la foudre que quelque chose
chez paquet de magnifiques
vous vous croyez à tous y compris aux
diables dans des cas pareils
alors j'ai fait quoi que j'ai flanqué ce
manuscrit j'aurais voulu le mettre dans
la cheminée mais je n'ai pas mis la
chemise à cause du petit garçon à cause
de ces parties de vie de vrais morceaux
de moi qui était devant c'est une espèce
d'instinct de conservation j'ai voulu
préserver ça en me disant bon ben je le
récupère est peut-être peut-être plus
tard dans un autre livre etc et j'ai
laissé dormir ce bouquin dans le placard
pendant un pendant à peu près un an
pendant 8 mois
et puis au bout de huit mois enfin vous
savez tous puisque vous écrivez ce que
c'est que l'écriture on ne perd pas de
vue en phase 6 ce qu'on a commencé alors
c'était une sorte de tourments c'est
venu me chercher je me suis dit non il
faut que je termine ce livre il n'y a
pas de raison pourquoi je vais
m'incliner mois devant 2 devant un coup
du sort on m'a volé ma gueule je vais
pas laisser voler un livre en somme je
résume des choses comme ça je reprends
mon bouquin et j'ai repris ce livre est
là alors ça ça n'a pas été de la
sucrette oui pourquoi
ben parce que ces petits pouvant table
de avec une idée pareille en ayant
véhicules drame parce qu'à ce moment là
il ya eu bifurcation c'est à dire que
parallèlement pendant que j'écrivais ce
livre moi j'assistais à l'instruction du
procès ben de dudu dubreu du brut a
perdu près tous les jeudis après midi
pendant un an
j'étais dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction et et j'assistais à cette
chose là et moi comme je rentrais le
lendemain matin je me mettais à ma
petite machine à écrire et je tapais
quoi une histoire qui n'était pas pareil
nom qui n'est pas parce que je suivais
mon canevas parce que je me disais je
vais pas non plus me laisser boulotter
parle par la vérité il faut que je
conserve ma tram il faut que j'écrive
mon livre mais la réalité quand même
maladie vous assaillir avec violences a
baissé ces enfin avec une violence je
crois que ça y est j'ai trouvé une
formule enfin trouvée elle s'est imposée
j'appelle ça le mâle d'horreur parce que
c'est c'est vraiment l'horreur qui se
précipitent sur coup deux
un matin ne plus retrouver son enfant
dans son lit et trouver à la place des
taches de sang et la lettre de monsieur
qui vous demandent de l'argent vous la
rendre c'est le bout de la nuit c'est
quelque chose d'indicible j'avais perdu
mon père deux mois avant et gt gt
terriblement traumatisé par la mort de
ce père qui a été merveilleux pour moi
eh ben je peux vous dire cimentage leur
demande pardon
d'un seul coup le chagrin a été stoppée
net c'était vous savez un craint un brin
cache un autre
un malheur en cache un autre et celui ci
était tellement énorme que brusquement
et l'image de mon père s'est estompée
mais tout de même
est ce que la réalité dans tellement
pressante tellement violente
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas elle nous a quand
même parfois guider votre main alors
pour raconter une histoire il ya une
chose qui a dû se produire
inconsciemment je suis conscient qu
inconsciemment s'est produit c'est que
on ne peut pas écrire en ayant vécu ça
continue et son histoire sans queue qui
est d'aider des brûlés vous comprenez et
jets de vapeur mais pas que quelque part
cette histoire mais par exemple de ce
détail qui m'a qui m'a fait sauter quand
je lis à ces gamins le personnage
l'écrivain vacher question d'acheter un
tableau de dali il va chez chez sorte
d'antiquaires au marchand de tableaux
qu'il appelle d'ailleurs il appelle
l'écurie l'appel victor hugo et il lui
dit ceci certains esprits mesquins
chuchote que c'est toi qui aurait
goupillé cet affectif mais oui je suis
persuadé qu'on vous avez aimé mais bien
sûr que je l'interdis dire parce que les
gens sont abominables
parce que les gens ont l'abomination à
fleur de peau parce qu'ils médiatement
quoi vous pensez bien un romancier un
romancier qui ont kidnappé la fille je
veux dire que en étant là ce soir même
je lance une espèce de défi
je viens de sortir un livre sur un rap
après avoir vécu c'est ce rap en sortant
d'un procès on se dit mais enfin c 'est
tout ça c'est effarant
et pourtant c'est c'est quand même là
c'est la réalité vous comprenez bien sûr
que des gens ont chuchoté ça je le sais
on me l'a répété on va dire mais c'est
un coup de pub ou parlé d'un coup de pub
parce que si on al'air cocu dans la vie
c'est bien un jour on vous prend vos
gosses sous votre toit
je veux dire que des coups de pub comme
ça
j'en ai quand vous voulez me faire
l'honneur de m'inviter ils sont de bon
aloi
j'ai pas besoin d'aller manigancé un
truc et puis je vois pas pourquoi un
type 7 après 18 ans de mitard bombe un
plaisir évident je crois oui c'est quand
même net va bien alors maintenant
frédéric dard revenons à la fiction oui
là dans la fiction donc votre belle
fille fait la belle fille de l'écrivain
est enlevée et puis l'argent est versé
et il l'a payé donc 6 2 millions c'est
la même c'est la même c'est la même
ensemble un moment c'est la même rançon
millions je suis tout à fait d'accord
c'est les manceaux et alors ils artaud
et à ce moment là et c'est là d'ailleurs
ce truc là
la très grande force de votre roman
c'est que parce qu'il a payé cet enfant
il se met à les écouter pendant des
années la corse a été tranquille c'est
pourquoi c'est parce qu'on l'avait
acheté on l'avait achetée aux génois
simplement et personne ne conteste et
rien ça cet effet chez un notaire je
pense on avait acheté la corse l'alsace
lorraine on n'a pas cédé des siècles à
se battre pour elle parce qu'on l'a
conquérait vous voyez ce sur sur des
champs de bataille des gens mourraient
pour ça et bien là je veux dire ça
procède de chez pas d'une réaction assez
assez semblable c'est que partir du
moment où ce type à payer sept enfants 1
il balance donc 800 millions d'anciens
francs 7 centimes c'est oui et il donne
ça pourra pour avoir cet argent il a
brusquement une espèce de sentiment de
pas de propriété mais il a fait quelque
chose pour elle c'est une seconde
naissance qu'il a accordé à sept enfants
il a récupéré grâce à son pognon peu
importe les moyens mais grâce à lui
grâce à lui il a eu ce il est une enfant
et attention ou là elle est à moi
maintenant un peu et l oms la fille ça
devient progressivement c'est pas du
jour au lendemain mais ça devient ça
devient progressivement sa fille
comprenez sans rivale c'est magnifique
merci bon alors
et là lors la police n'intervient pas
d'ailleurs c'est ses larmes en ont mais
je vous dis parce que dans le temps dans
le canevas j'avais fait parce que s'il
devait intervenir là dedans alors j'ai
écrit un bouquin du double oui alors
c'est l'écrivain qui lui va démasquer le
kidnappeur alors c'est l'écrivain et la
kidnapper c'est un concours de
circonstance sous fait quelques
progressivement ils sont mais
intéressant parce qu'à un moment vous
dites un romancier qu'est ce que c'est
sinon un homme qui devine oui mais je
crois qu'il ya de ça il ya un côté
divinatoires chez les romanciers
je pense que nous nous en sommes je
crois que nous passons notre vie à
écrire des vérités inventé je pense que
oui tout à fait tout à fait ça et
parfois il ya même des livres prémunit
temps mais m'est arrivé une fois dans ma
vie doit inscrire un tiers de l'ide de
quelque chose que kim est arrivé par la
suite je crois que le corps sans les
messages qu'il reçoit je sais simplement
ses coûts de soin d'eux-mêmes
intérieurement sans s'en rendre compte
côté médium de quelque chose de soi
c'est à dire que vraiment si on raconte
tellement qu'il est obligé à un moment
donné de dire la vérité
il ya aussi comme les prophètes
alors on pourrait penser que le le
kidnappeur démasqué que voilà un livre
qui or il va avoir un apn comme on dit
or pas du tout ça se termine dans le
drame is to que le père fait ce père ce
nouveau père va être victime mais bon la
fin est bon pour la nana je dis pas la
fin je veux dire que ça se termine d'une
manière effrayant dans la noirceur la
plus totale dans le désespoir le 10 mai
alors là je raccroche avec la réalité
parce que j'ai constaté que un des
drames de la vie enfin tout au moins de
la mienne consiste à voir ses enfants
fiche le camp à voir ses enfants grandir
vivre leur propre vie c'est affreux ce
que je dis pas ce que vous avez
m'objecter que c'est la vie que j'avais
fait autant vis à vis de mes parents et
que c'est la chaîne etc etc et reconnu
bon d'accord il n'empêche que pour moi
voir grandir et se détacher de moi mes
enfants
moi qui l' esprit j'ai pas de possession
je suis je suis un père
m voyez c'est quelque chose d'atroce et
est ce que je raconte là dedans c'est un
petit peu ce sentiment exacerbé de la
fidh de l'enfant qui s'en va qui vous
quittez qui vous laisse comme comme un
conte sur une île quoi excusez moi vous
la reprenait par l'écriture d'une
certaine façon ça vous encore plus que
la rançon mais ce qui me frappe beaucoup
c'est que c'est aussi le commissaire san
antonio qui est là et qui a produit
quelque chose d'énorme
alors on dirait que d'une certaine façon
ça pourrait ne pas ne pas cesser et puis
d'un seul coup
frédéric dard préface préface zones hors
et d'une préface monsieur déjà lieu mais
je croyais déjà lieu que ça pouvait
s'entendre littéralement que savait déjà
eu lieu
ah non non non je ne suis pas d'accord
mais alors ça je le garde pour un
antonio à l'écouté pas ça n'est pas
exclu et quelque chose a déjà eu lieu
mais aussi quelque chose et arrive
définitivement je dire que alors il une
autre une autre hypothèse c'est est ce
que vous pourriez continuer indéfiniment
à produire des aventures du commissaire
san antonio ou bien que vous bien est ce
qu'avec cette irruption de la réalité
quelque chose s'arrête parce qu'il est
possible aussi d'imaginer que la réalité
vient et produite par la fiction à la
façon de borja en tout cas moi je suis
sûr que quelque chose est définitivement
arrêtée avec san antonio
c'est mon avis passe quelque chose
réponse j'ai pas ses sentiments puis
vint me [ __ ] la trouille la plume
entre les jambes
[Rires]
je ne pense pas non je j'ai l'impression
que c'est un autre jus
les san antonio c'est quelque chose d
ça fait partie de ma vie ma démarche de
magny-cours employés on mange on dort on
se couche il se passe il se passe la vie
- j'ai écrit des san antonio c'est rivas
ne vais pas été horrifié en lisant
toutes les scènes de sexualité dans le
livre de san antonio de la pudeur même
alors vraiment choqué oui je pense pas
ça je comprends parce que quand j'ai lu
le livre de monsieur basse non mais je
vais pas anticiper mercier l'histoire
d'un gars qui se réserve qui préserve de
ce que vous appelez sa semence est un
bon je peux vous dire que l'aja
dispersent à non parce que moi au diable
l'avarice
enfin l'homme a été choqué par
l'écrivain mais l'homme est choqué mais
comment dit ceci vous l'un de l'autre
comment dissocier vous l'homme de
l'écrivain moi j'ai l'impression que ça
fait ou vous n'êtes pas de moi ce serait
très difficile il va créer un personnage
alors que l'homme vit sa vie à lui
et c'est un personnage qui est en dehors
de lui il est obligé de composer de de
faire intervenir toutes sortes chose qui
suit qui lui sont extérieurs je pense
bien que dans mon histoire et il y a un
p'tit gars qui me ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau on va y venir
bon ça sera ma question c'est antonio
miss intimidant parce que beauchemin ont
fait des complexes hier j'étais avec
françoise xenakis qui m'a dit tu as été
atteint en face de monsieur vincenot
méfie toi avec son accent bourguignon tu
va poser lui répondent
et tu vas te laisser avoir bon mais
alors ça c'est la fin du de la petite
préface de frédéric dard est cependant
après vous signé après donc à présent
dénommée lapine joséphine ce ne fut
jamais plus comme avant jamais plus
personne n'était mort dans l'aventuré
mais quelque chose si alors qu'est-ce
qui est venu écouter et vous prennez
c'est ce mot c'est ce que j'ai dis parce
que je m'en suis pratiquement expliquée
en cour d'assises pour faire comprendre
aux juristes des pauvres
ce mode de barbus il dit le bonheur
cette chose qui n'existe pas et qui
pourtant journée plus eh bien je crois
que sans en être conscient
nous vivions avant dans une espèce de
paix de naples on passa du bonheur un
trop grand mot mais mais mais une paix à
c'est à ces merveilleuses ma femme
joséphine moi voyez on était s'était
planté dans un cocon et ce cocon éclaté
ce cocon éclaté cet incident bon on a
retrouvé la petite on a même retrouvé la
rançon mais c'est plus pareil
on nous a volé une gosse de 12 ans et on
m'a rendu une gueuse 17 18
parce qu'elle a et est brusquement en
quelques jours il ya eu une maturité
phénoménal qui s'est opéré chez elle et
c'est une autre enfant c'est une autre
enfant et et je sais pas moi je suis
prêt à la gorge je les regardais je me
dis c'est pas possible je sais que tout
ça aurait eu lieu mais cela aurait eu
lieu d'une façon il tire et ça se serait
située par fractions je pense alors que
la passe d'un seul coup et ça c'était
pouvant table ça vraiment j'ai du mal à
me remettre trêve de gaudriole c'est dur
c'est dur assumer 12 sur le livre les
larmes de san antonio
oui parce que enfin je viens pas chialer
à votre émission 1 c'est pas le problème
mais mais c'est très dur et c'est en ce
sens excusez moi je pense simplement
qu'il ya quelque chose qui peut changer
les airs au sens où un individu serait
un dédale vous savez les dédales qu'on
voit dans les journaux il faut trouver
la sortie et chaque individu un dédale
strictement singulier et on dirait que
là vous avez trouvé une voix chacun sa
voie donc et que parfois pour quelques
uns il faut le malheur pour pour arriver
à la vérité
et moi je pense que d'abord vous êtes
vous êtes toujours vrai je dire vraiment
san antonio le commissaire san antonio
une partie de vous même comme je suis je
crois que c'est plus un mais
non là là c'est fin fin de la fiction la
réalité vos amis devant c'est devant
cette forme de vérité et malheureusement
pour vous il a fallu que ce soit par le
malheur oui bonne motivation bon henri
vincenot un comme ça vous trahissez la
bourgogne en faisant l'éloge de la
bretagne
oui enfin ça c'est parce c'est tout une
petite histoire vous permettez que je
raconte en deux minutes quand j'ai eu
cinq ans j'ai fait une arme était tombé
sur la poitrine
voyez ce que je veux dire dans ce temps
là ça s'appelait comme ça on le
connaissait pas les antibiotiques et on
m'a très bien guéri d'ailleurs le
médecin du village de commarin côte-d'or
m'a guéri mais quand ça a été fini la
10e gala lui faut de l'yonne
alors qui dit y est dit goémon qui dit
game on dit rochette bras tu tombes et
on va envoyer ce bal en bretagne alors
on a mis le doigt sur la carte de la
bretagne parce que en bourgogne il y à
déjà soixante dix ans bientôt 70 ans ou
la bretagne c'est très loin alors on a
mis le doigt enfin mon grand père mon
père ont mis le doigt sur une carte des
côtes du nord parce que c'est celle qui
vient en tête du dow botha et et puis
parce que c'est écrit c'est de rochers
le nom le doigt est tombé sur un village
qui s'appelle pratique quand on a écrit
au maire on a écrit notamment aux maires
qui était à ce moment là en train de se
faire casser la figure au chemin des
dames c'était en 17
et puis c'est un vieux pêcheur qui a
trouvé cette pub qui était adjoint au
maire il a hésité à l'ouvré puis l'ayant
lu il a dit envoyer votre cas il y sera
je suis ici comme chez lui et c'est
alors là j'ai eu
j'ai profité de l'hospitalité et la
générosité bretonne je serais presque
tenté de lancer un appel est un salut
toute la bretagne
si vous voulez je peux le faire en
breton à huy ha vu ton breton d'amener
le brési ce que dany tu des rails ou
précaires cléon
queen and some briec samba do
dictionnaire des grèves voilà tout ce
que je voulais mais ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'on voit très bien quand vous
parlez à la fois le breton et puis aussi
un breton doit gagner le patois bien je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi d'humour
comme le village où je suis tombé comme
ça par hasard c'est la frontière
linguistique
c'était la frontière linguistique elle a
reculé un petit peu entre le breton et
le patois gagne voilà alors ça vous a
peut-être étonné d'entendre c'est
peut-être la première fois contre lens
des mots en breton à l'émission approche
non non pas du tout dans une émission
sur la bretagne
oui cela s'était prononcé de là ont été
prononcées avec l'accent bourguignon
c'est très particulier c'est particulier
mais vous dites même que
au début à gergy donc l'enseignement de
ces le compte à rebours au temps qui
passait dans les villages et voilà ce
qui explique un petit peu le roman c'est
à dire que il est calqué sur un conte
breton qui lui est comme le roman le si
vous voulez la glorification de la
continence viril
alors le personnage le personnage vient
aux vacances en bretagne il est il a été
il a réussi son concours d'entrée à
l'école coloniale
oui l'école que le lien et puis donc
qu'ils aillent privat ouvriers bretonne
il est séduit par la langue
et puis il tombait tout d'un coup au
groenland breton oui donné par match
avec philippe cayla petite nièce de la
grand'mare garrigues philippe qui a sa
statue à saint brieuc dans les jardins
du musée du palais de justice dont elle
est à côté d'un atoll de brasser de la
grande conteuse et celle là c'était
scène son arrière petite nièce bon et
elle nous régaler de ses comptes qui
sont sensationnelles qui sont vraiment
on retrouve nos oreilles oublier si ça
existe oui il y à un bouquin qui
s'appelle le mabinogi ans qui était
publié il coûte très cher ailleurs mais
dira qu'ils ramassent tous ces
contretemps ya la version de l'otan et
la version en français
à côté c'est assez étonnant mais damien
aspe bilingue dans votre roman ici ben
oui oui je viens j'y tenais à conserver
cette atmosphère bretonne au moyen de
l'annoncer pas bilingue traduction
simultanée du breton oui j'ai mis la
traduction 1 parce qu'il ya quelques
phrases en breton effectivement et j'ai
mis la traduction une vulgate un
français voilà alors alors que cette vie
ce jeune homme a été frappé par ses
comptes et en même temps il a vu dans la
société
deux jeunes filles donc il va on connait
c'est une mélodie ne la connaissais pas
et c'était une quelque chose de
merveilleux
il est il est devenu amoureux de cette
fille mais l'on disparaît toutes les
deux et il a cherché à les retrouver et
s est la recherche c'est permanent de
cette fille nous sommes dans la dans la
prochaine voilà c'est la recherche
permanente de cette fille pendant trois
ans on emmène cata mais au départ il a
vu cette fille il a dit bon c'est la
femme de ma vie et il décide de rester
pur alors vous rassembler au héros du
compte c'était pour elle que je
travaillerai que je me garderai le corps
pur comme une âme le rêve des scènes
c'est sa maîtresse est un conforme au
compte à l'ensemble des comptes
d'artistes c'est le chevalier qui à la
recherche du graal est le graal
finalement c'est la femme est alors il y
a du mérite quand même à rester pur
pendant ces trois années
c'est parce que il va il ya deux fois il
ya deux femmes superbes kivu roman se
donne à lui
oui et pas du tout il re plus il ya même
un curé qui le tente de côté en lui
disant mais il faut vous faire curer bon
inutile 20 tous ces obstacles a dit pas
plus long parce que c'est grave c'est
que monsieur vince tôt et 10 qui le
tente
à l'époque présente d'être curé c'est
une tentation stamm est la seule ville
en obstacle qui est placée par l'église
10 ans mais quand même dire quand même
dire si masnau que votre héros va
ensuite il ay les diplômes les colonials
il va au maroc parce que il va au bar le
poursuivre parce que la jeune fille est
que lorsqu'il va la trouver
ça va être une déception affreux bien
sûr parce qu'il s'est fait bien entendu
au cours des quatre ans où il n'a pas pu
la voir parce que le compte en question
le compte d'un ton est remarquable je
sais pas si vous avez vu la similitude
d'ailleurs ce c'est un héros qui
s'appelle conan qui est qui voit passer
une jeune fille à cheval cette jeune
fille marche au pas ou pas ton cheval
bien entendu lui saute sur son cheval
pic des deux gestionnaires ballottés
pour m'abattre a t il à bout trotter
d'abord galoper ensuite le grand galop
ensuite elle continue à marcher au pas
et ne rattrape pas alors ça c'est
l'image de ces trois ans profite pas et
quand il la rattrape elle s'évanouit et
au pied d'un palais il entre dans ce
palais est là il trouve une femme
mais alors si ce n'est pas la même mais
c'est celle qu'il attendait c'est celle
pour laquelle il était prêt
voilà voilà le conte breton et qui
dirige en somme tout le roman tourne
mais le jeune homme s'est promis de
suivre le programme du roman essai du
conte et c'est ce que vous êtes promis
que vous étiez jeune parfaitement bien
big pas des deux importants aussi aussi
j'en ai mis en baie de lannion se
réserve pour la fin oui parfaitement
vous êtes comme ça risque est
parfaitement pur pour le marier à
l'affrètement vie alors vous raconter
c'est une recette que je donne parce que
c'est une recette de bonheur et tous
ceux qui veulent enfin être heureux en
ménage tout au moins nous quand on faire
autant c'est oui c'est très facile mais
évidemment on est très loin c'est vous
qui parce que je le sais enfin toute
façon ce qui me concerne c'est trop tard
mais dont il est vrai qu'on est loin de
bérurier là ça c'est sûr c'est l'envié
oui c'est métaphysique de bérurier alors
oui et l'oeuvre de chair donc
s'accomplit dans le mariage c'est le
sait c'est sa seule raison d'être
derrière na qui parle de l'acte sexuel
le jeune homme le dis parce que je ne
sais pas tout à fait moi bien entendu
enfin comme dans tous les romans il y a
une part de soi puis une pas qu'on a
l'imagination mais vous pensez pas quand
même que ce récit va en étonner plus
d'un aujourd'hui les jeunes gens ont dit
mais alors un snow qu'est-ce qui nous
raconte la finale online
les hommes doivent rester vierge
jusqu'au mariage alors la rente comme ça
regrette
oui mais je viens d'avoir aujourd'hui
une critique de je ne sais pas qui
d'ailleurs c'était ça m'a été donné par
la maison de noël où j'étais tout à
l'heure on va découper un rocha et un
article dans lequel le critique dont je
ne connais pas le nom excusez-moi 10 mai
est arrivé de cette nouvelle chasteté
qui est en ce moment à la mode à la mode
en amérique
je suis persuadé mois de la mode vent
venir en france et que vous êtes donc le
précurseur et je viens peut m'être fait
mans mais parfaitement je suis pas un
précurseur je suis un rénovateur parce
que vous savez cette vieille histoire de
la chasteté de la continence d
ils viennent comme le monde vous savez
il n'ya pas à pas toujours eu des
san-antonio c'est pour ça que je suis
arrivé au bon moment là vous pensez que
vous pourrez vivre dans les années qui
viennent la chute de 100 pays et au
niveau de bérurier alors et la montée de
il y à un mois et demi que le livret ça
n'est pas d'affronter montréal ni à la
montée oui donc bien au fait sentir mais
oui il ya un mois et demi que le livre
est sorti je pense à mon ami j'ai déjà
une trentaine de lettres donc donné aux
coups de lettres d'un jeune fille jeu
qu'il avait pensé les apporter mais qui
me disent enfin voilà un homme comme
nous voudrions à trouver ah oui donc
aider l'être aussi de vieux bonshommes
alors le évidemment c'est plus facile à
eux de dire même et les jeunes filles en
question je vous assure c'est
enthousiasmant c'est ces lettres de
jeunes filles ça prouve une chose c'est
que en ce moment ceux qui se croient
obligés les jeunes qui seront obligés
d'afficher une certaine liberté grande
liberté dont ils disent pas ce qu'ils
pensent ni disent même pas ce qu'ils
font ils ont ils en avant tous les jours
ça fait très bien
on roule les mécaniques ont dû au jeu
complet avec une telle punition en
revanche du coussac des 36 je prouverai
c'est encore plus vrai que paul le jeune
homme qui est là c'est peut-être vrai
brevets il y en a et la rue est là mais
ça vient peut-être de certains exemples
donnés dans le livre bon et alors où des
lions à la fin du roman vous profitez de
cette fiction pour donner un peu vos
idées et notamment sur la femme parce
que parce que votre personnage a même en
devient vendeur dans un supermarché en
fait on ne s'appelle pas à l'époque un
supermarché et alors vous dites que les
supermarchés sont fait d'une certaine
manière pour pervertir les femmes bien
entendu mais bien entendu mais il ya
qu'à vous faire quelques études
notamment quand j'étais jeune c'était
pas à l'école coloniale que j'ai fait
c'est à l'école des hautes études
commerciales
on a eu les premiers cours de publicité
tout le monde rigolait gentiment à des
cours de publicité bon il nous était
enseigné les vérités que j'ai nommé la
qui venait d'ailleurs
n'est pas pour revendre il faut séduire
la femme l'homme difficile mais la femme
alors il faut des coûts certaines
couleurs du rouge
il faut certaines musiques a surtout
arrêter la musique
si vous arrêtez la musique les femmes
n'achète plus il faut de la musique la
trompette vous fait vendre des objets de
sport d'équipé marcher ou pas
et puis le offenbach offenbach c'est
pour les dessous féminins
quand on passe une musique d'offenbach
d'une valse de vienne
eh bien ces dames se précipite sur le
sur le rayon article disons de lingerie
de là je sens que les grands magasins
m'ont offert un pont d'or j'avais beau
théorie vient vous savez j'ai vendu est
ce que je raconte là c'est le jeune
homme qui qui en acteur en réalité c'est
moi j'ai commencé aussi dans comme lui
dans ses magasins il y avait un stock
important de chocolat dans les caves et
je ne sais pas c'était du chocolat je
pense que c'est vrai l'épisode sévère
asie et que vous vendez c'est vrai mais
c'est formidable
alors je trouve ça et je demande au
magasinier qu'est ce que c'est que ça
aubry dit si c'est ça c'est une tonne de
chocolat ou enfin je ne sais pas
800 kg de chocolat chaud qu'on n'a
jamais cessé de la camelote
il est devenu tout blanc alors il a je
me suis dit il faut le vendre en
application des principes qu'on m'avait
appris à l'école des hautes études
commerciales pour vendre il faut bon
déjà certains arguments alors j'ai fait
un étalage magnifique la vitrine des
états unis quand question
et puis j'ai mis une belle affiche rouge
si possible parce qu'il faut du rouge le
rouge
exit la femme bon et si tout au moins
électoraux excitent auto moi c'est un
spa acheteurs alors j'avais me ht le
chocolat machin le seul qui blanchissent
c'est une preuve évidemment de mauvaises
qualités bien entendu eh bien on a
liquidé la tonne de chocolat au moins
deux parce que je trouve extraordinaire
chez vous me suivez ce taux si vous
permettez c'est que vous prônez à la
fois la chasteté larnack
laminé bey abina très bien sûr si vous
voulez gagner votre vie confortablement
il faut faire larnack voilà bon là qu'on
se le dise tout le monde le sait bien
mais michel castillo je vous ai vu chez
les têtes dont henri vincenot parler de
rester babala si j'ose dire un peu mais
non mais c'est très bien vous aviez pas
aimé avoir un grand père comme
maintenant je n'ai pas cessé pègre
empêche donc c'est un peu tard et vous
avez élever vos enfants ou petits
enfants dans le respect de ma foi j'ai
essayé au sol et j'ai pas fait mais j'ai
essayé de leur expliquer ces choses mais
vos petits enfants ils disent
ils trouvent sont d'accord et bien moi
j'en ai l'impression oui enfin c'était
difficile à dire ça ils peuvent dire
blanc moi et puis noir ailleurs c'est
moi je n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien
en tout cas en tout cas je crois leur
avoir inculqué à tous autant qu'ils sont
le respect de la femme de la femme
génératrice mgr et génératrice c'est son
rôle c'est j'allais dire le feu si
madame simone de beauvoir vous écoute et
puis madame yvette roudy après
l'émission qui est passée savez sur le
deuxième sexe mais pas vu cette émission
deuxième siècle
c'est la troisième émission j'ai passé
là vous théorie sur la femme évidemment
sont pas tout à fait conformes à celles
qui sont ont été signés dans cette
émission est un état faire bien alors on
va terminer avec
alain barrère et rimbaud d'abord quand
et où sont venues cette passion pour un
beau alors je vais vous répondre le plus
simplement possible parce que je suis
sûr que chacun aurait du mal à dire
quand commence la quête simplement
j'étais un cancre et mon père m'a mis
dans un lycée
en suisse et il y avait une revue qui
s'appelait le bateau ivre alors j'ai
sauté dans le bateau ivre à 17 ans et
j'étais tellement bouleversé la lecture
du texte de bateau ivre que je n'ai pas
pu le lire ou delà du premier le 4 1
c'est comme ça que venue cette passion
alors j'ai vu dans le monde il y avait
un reportage chez vous de raphaël sorin
l'expliquez vous avez une bibliothèque
rimbaldienne absolument phénoménale vous
avez absolument tout ce qui a été écrit
sur un beau oui enfin c'est une rebelle
de tech mais ce n'est qu'un des éléments
de la recherche parce que la seule chose
qui compte c'est d'abord de dire que
c'est le plus grand vous permettez c'est
le plus grand c'est le plus grand et pas
seulement parce que c'est le plus grand
écrivain
à mon avis celui qui importe est tout de
suite la langue à son point
d'incandescence mais aussi parce que
c'est aussi celui qui était au fond
indifférent à la capacité d'écrire
sainement et qui assignait à la
littérature un but suprême celui de
changer la vie et alors quand il s'est
aperçu que ça marchait pas il est passé
tout de suite à autre chose mais avec la
même radicalité il fallait changer la
poésie alors du vinci a peu de poésie
avant lui à dégager et ensuite on
continue à chercher ailleurs et il ya la
même je crois il est la même exigence au
cours de toute sa vie
donc quand rimbaud par quitte la france
pour et quitte la poésie aussi pour la
pour l'abyssinie c'est parce qu'il
s'aperçoit que la poésie ne peut pas
changer le monde c'est ça oui je sais
c'est la principale raison
je crois oui parce que vous savez la
poésie ça a l'air d'un exercice ou d'un
loisir ou de quelque chose qu'on fait
dans dans l'ennui et il nous reste au
fond où plus de la poésie que une
conception romantique enfin la la la
publicité boursin quoi
je crois que lui était quelqu'un qui
pensaient que la poésie pouvait changer
la vie vraiment et il a en effet échoué
et millas et ça en étant enfant puisque
ça caille a cessé à 19 ans 19 au 21 mai
l'essentiel pour nous et qu'il les pense
est qu'ils aient cru vraiment et qu'il
est toujours cru avec intransigeance ce
qu'il faisait à l'ab aurait alors vous
êtes parti c'est sûr qu'il est passé si
ya une chose qui me trouble dans fin
d'un rêve ou c'est sait qui il est
presque renier en somme ça ne va pas il
n'aimait pas qu'on lui en parle il se
fâchait il avait il avait un rejet de ce
qu'il avait ça ne se veut dire que donc
ça a été bien tranché sa rupture avec la
poésie c'est une chose après il a
démarré à travers le monde
en grand marcheur liars sakifo
prodigieux certainement mon fils a
affronté l'europe vit certainement
définitive mais en portant toujours
cette exigence
ce qui m'a frappé c'est de retrouver ce
pays l'abyssinie alors vous êtes allé en
78 1918 ce qui est extraordinaire
77 c'est que vous avez le même âge que
rimbaud comme vous êtes allé en
abyssinie 27 ans le ce qui est le plus
impressionnant pour moi c'est de savoir
que je ne survivrais pas 15 jours dans
un pays où il a trimé comme un âne pour
le citer pendant dix ans comment est
tout à fait fascinant lorsqu'on appuie
on arrive dans cet empire deux fois demi
grand comme la france c'est de
s'apercevoir que chaque jour ils
devaient risquer sa vie il y avait un
jeune explorateur qui s'appelait
lucereau et la rive à aden en 1880 et
balade en abyssinie avec de la
strychnine il ya un autre explorateur
qui s'appelle h il sera frais et qui lui
se transporte en abyssinie avec du
cyanure pour éviter la castration
et puis le patron d' alfred bardey
d'arthur rimbaud alfred bardey se
transporte avec des fusée éclairantes et
arthur rimbaud arrive à 27 ans dans cet
empirisme transport climat dans les
poches avec du dabo colo des céréales
comme s'il y avait un désir de de
risquer sa vie de la terne et alors le
plus impressionnant encore c'est de
s'apercevoir que dans ce pays il aurait
pu recevoir de ces gens que l'on
rencontre au moins une leçon de sagesse
la façon de vivre ici et maintenant que
peuvent nous apprendre les africains et
pas du tout il continue toujours à
cavaler parce qu'il n'a jamais cessé de
marcher ça c'est l'une des grandes
constantes de sa vie jamais cessé de
marcher et il continue de marcher alors
que cherche-t-il et vous savez ce qui me
qui me ce qui me scandalise et vraiment
je crois il ya être allé sans a priori
d'ailleurs savait simplement un petit
carnet de route et madame lachenal
philippe soupault arthur ashe pêcheurs
nous avions l'intention de faire un
livre sur rimbaud négociants et puis ce
livre s'est développée pour moi parce
que il y a des livres auxquels comme dit
georges bataille on se sent profondément
tenue et puis grâce à madame nationale
j'ai pu confier le texte complet à denis
roche pour la collection de fictions et
compagnes heures c'est ce qui est le
plus frappant c'est cette forme
d'exigences qui était totale permanente
et j'ai fini tout simplement par
comprendre mais pour moi et sans
l'imposer que rambo n'est pas un
écrivain même si je dis c'est le plus
grand même si la figure la plus pure
mais qu'il est quelqu'un qui est passé
par l'écriture comme parmi les vraiment
mille autres projets toujours à la
recherche de quelque chose et ça c'est
la dimension de la quête
le montrer de kia qui a été un
caravaniers hors pair 40 km par jour à
cheval un jour à pied sans jamais donc
perdre la vie mais qu'il a été un piètre
négociants oui ça fait pas vendre je ne
savais pas vendre alors vous faites
justice d'une accusation qu'on a porté
sur un bon à savoir qu'il a était
trafiquant d'esclaves marchand escape
c'est pas vrai moi je ne cherche pas à
défendre une idée de rimbaud a priori je
crois pouvoir le dire il aurait été
marchands d'esclaves ça aurait été très
bien en avril sera terrible oui mais
alors le fait c'est que d'abord quand on
regarde les documents s'aperçoit que
c'est littéralement impossible
je me permets de renvoyer un chapitre
j'essaie de documenter ça mais la
question qui devenait intéressante pour
moi c'est qu'étant donné qu'il n'était
pas possible que rimbaud se livrent le
trafic d'esclaves et je disais mon
scandale tout à l'heure j'ai ici parce
que à partir du moment où rimbaud
abandonne la poésie il devient il
n'intéresse plus 16 décrit la intéresse
plus on le traite de négociants
bourgeois
raciste et colonialiste enfin et quand
on va vivre simplement ou essayer de
vivre pour soi
cette expérience on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
j'ai dire dans cette façon de souffrir
une forme de de rachat c'est ça qui est
à mon avis un modèle v6 de claudel sur
lui vous citez je cite souvent
prudemment fin évidemment c'est le
mystique à l'état sauvage mystique lp
oui c'est à dire ce qui est très
frappant c'est que j'ai le sentiment que
c'est quelqu'un qui après avoir beaucoup
souffert et après plusieurs échecs
étant donné cette intransigeance qu'il
est qu'il a signé à la poésie a tenté de
se racheter d'abord de fuir et
d'occident dans lequel les valeurs de
papy vincenot n'arrive pas à satisfaire
à un jeune homme de 18 ans ou de 17 ans
18 ans 880 ou aujourd'hui fuyant cet
occident là il tente de ceux de se
racheter
il est et il a fait des choses très mal
n'est ce pas il a fait des choses très
mal pour lui
pensait-il qui était conditions de la
transformation de la poésie du langage
la vie et il a dit là il a dit sur son
lit d'hôpital à sa soeur isabelle
pourquoi parce que c'était mal alors on
dirait qu'il va à la limite du monde
connu à l'époque quand la dessine ici
loin comme pour se racheter alors les
esclaves c'est ça parce que je crois
qu'ils n'arrivent pas et c'est ça qui
est le plus pathétique tout il n'y
arrive pas il voudrait bien devenir
riche
il voudrait bien se marier il y a
toujours en lui cette forme de
l'impossible qui est un des plus beaux
textes d'une saison en enfer et qui fait
qu'il repousse toujours
et lorsqu'il m'a le plus bouleversé car
au fond ce livre pour moi avec une
émotion c'est de m'apercevoir qu'il y
avait un destin à une chose
d'inéluctable une globalisation
marcheurs qui finit unijambiste je
trouve ça extraordinaire mais on parle
beaucoup de rameau on parle pas de vous
puisque je suis présent je voudrais dire
à quel point je trouve remarquable au
travail et vous savez la pensée qui
m'est venue quand j'ai eu fini votre
livre je me suis dit j'ai l'impression
que blu ray est une oeuvre posthume dans
un beau il y à quelque chose il ya un
prolongement vous je veux dire que ça va
plus c'est une espèce de prolongement de
sun ça fait partie de rimbaud je trouve
que c'est tellement grand ce que vous
avez fait tellement magistral moi c'est
un livre en plus qui m'a bouleversé
cette raison parce que je parlais tout à
l'heure vous que jose chez lattès
possible mais parce que si vous voulez
si mystique il y à quelque part il est
dans ce livre la série hbo c'est ça le
mysticisme je veux dire que c'est lui
qui crèvent de soif d'absolu
c'est pas le fait de garder sa semence
et le fait de creuser les nerfs tendus
la peau temps exact est de demander la
réponse à une éthique c'est la possible
adieu la possible alors faire
l'impossible partir ailleurs
le rêve de lorient partir toujours ne
pas être satisfait de l'itie traversée
l'ordure ocldi osé blasphémer aux épices
et souhaite une vie d'homme
alors ça c'est à dire c'est sa liste ici
ne sais pas ça consiste pas à savoir ce
qu'on regarde les secondeurs il a tout
donné
il est allée aux limites et je crois que
c'est la figure pour ça la plus pure on
aurait des conceptions différentes à la
pureté mais je crois qu'il ya au moins
quelque chose en commun c'est la
protestation d'innocence qu'on trouve
dans le livre de michel del castillo
même homme pressé dans la nuit du décret
c'est une protestation d'innocence qu'on
veut qu'ils aient wii qui est très fort
tout à fait fondamentale voyez je
croyais en abyssinie qu'arthur rimbaud
pensais que tout ce qu'il avait fait
comme il l'a dit à sa soeur s'était très
mal mais en réalité c'est quelque chose
de beaucoup plus fondamental c'est le
fait même d'être à partir du moment où
on est limité physiquement comme si on
pouvait ne pas accéder à cette forme
d'eau de laquelle recherche physiquement
40 km par jour toute sa vie c'est ça la
protestation fondamentale alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya une maison rabot qui
vous avez trouvé là-bas
non vous savez ce qu'est le plus
fascinant c'est que le temps est
suspendu et alors on voit ce que rimbaud
à vue on a l'impression d'être dans un
livre d'image du 19e alors il n'y a plus
de maison rambo et elle se trouve sur la
couverture d'un des deux livres parus à
l'aide en c'est en hommage à cette
maison quand le nom de rimbaud est
devenu célèbre
on lui a donné la plus belle maison du
village fait le vrai rimbaud il est
aussi sur deux dans son jardin de
bananes bon le il ya aussi ce ce nom de
rimbaud gravé sur une pierre d'un temple
hill quoi la loupe à louxor alors qui
sait que ce nom de rimbaud alors il ya
la photographie d'ailleurs de la pierre
dans le livre qu'est ce que c'est que ce
sera un beau jeu c'est une énigme et je
crois que cette signature est juste
comme énigme
c'est à dire salut moi c'est ça qui m'a
le plus bouleversé de commencer le
voyage dans la neige violette des
ardennes et puis j'ai compris que pour
moi il s'achevait devant cette signature
le solaire entre le désert dans lequel
rimbaud à la danse ou faire d'eux des
souffrances inimaginables qui me comme
il le dit lui-même vous le prendre sur
parole entre ce désert et la nage
c'est comme s'il était toujours comme il
le dit d'un poème du même des heures à
la même nuit quelqu'un qui était un
homme absent du monde et j'ai quelques
raisons alors cette fois biographique
détaillées sur le thème de la filature
de penser qu'ils étaient en effet en
egypte
à cette époque et si comme on ne pourra
jamais le savoir
c'est sans importance ce qui est
important que ce que les justes dis-je
au sens où il aura son nom ou quelqu'un
pour lui aura gravé son nom en egypte au
pays de l'éternité et de la naissance de
décrypter et armement vous poser de
question que je trouve fondamentale et
s'il avait helaba connu la poésie du
réel
est ce que c'est vrai la question oui
alors on est tenté de le penser on est
pensée tenté de penser qu'après la
poésie et son échec on va vivre le real
c'est une position juste philippe
soupault on en a souvent parlé
en réalité quand on voit le pays on
s'aperçoit que la poésie était vraiment
un exercice littéraire quelque chose
qu'elle y est vraiment la médiation du
langage et que rimbaud à tous tout est
prouvée souffle la poésie du réel on est
tenté de dire surréaliste cette sarah
beaucoup mais en réalité il avait cette
forme de deux de pureté de sa pureté
chapeau en mai 0,2 sauvées la poésie du
real était d'abord il était chaque jour
il risque sa vie chaque jour pour aller
je vous dis que je supporterai pas une
vie survivrait pas 15 jours
oui c'est très frappant dans votre lutte
elle montre que les dangers auxquels il
a échappé pendant dix ans c'est
incroyable incroyable les fauchages
voulu connaître les danakil par exemple
c'est la tribu une des tribus que les
ethnologues les plus nuancée nomme les
pires sauvage blatter ils avaient ils
mettaient des testicules de frangy les
étrangers autour de leur cou pour
pouvoir se marier et ses mains se
posaient pas les mêmes heures et par
exemple
également il fallait connaître les
maladies comment survivre comment se
nourrir chaque jour
et ça pendant dix ans alors les deux
lignes à deux livres il ya selon le
récit de votre voyage donc qui se trouve
là dans vos éditions du seuil rimbaud en
abyssinie et puis alors celui là qui est
publié donc chez lachenal héritèrent
alors c'est un livre qui est au complet
puisqu'il ya donc votre récit bien
entendu on peut découper différemment
mais il y a alors une chronologie sur un
beau il y a des lettres de rimbaud
notamment à séméac 6000 et qui sont
inédits sous forme de fac similé curieux
c'est qu'il s'adressait à sa mère et à
sa soeur une méche heures de solitude
totale être la mère qu'il garde sur sa
civière jusqu'au méat seule lettre celle
du 18 octobre 2007 il est passé du net
les sanguinaires lors il ya donc ces
lettres il y a le texte de
de philippe soupault etc et puis alors
il y a donc les photographie de rimbaud
ces autos photographie on envie de dire
j'espère que oui parce que quand il est
en abyssinie une photographie que lui
même trois fois
il est aussi des dessins des travaux
graphiques d'arthur h pêcheurs et puis
il ya des documents et d'ethnologie sur
la piscine hits de l'époque et des
photos françois margolin
mais ce qui m'a frappé bon vous voyez
ces deux c'est difficile parce que je
suis revenu avec un tout petit carnet
visage et madame nationale comme j'ai
dit ma autorisés à publier la version
complète là mais je crois que je ne suis
pas où ça et donc c'est une version
antérieure développer différentes mais
ce qui est le plus frappant c'est qu'au
fond on n'a jamais fini et je crois pas
j'ai fini ce livre je les sais mon
émotion pour moi achevé mais un moment
simplement on s'arrête d'ailleurs vous
avez quelle annonce 35 encore 200 vous
continuer puisque parade sauvage c'est
une revue d'études rimbaldienne qui
vient de sortir numéro un et vous donner
des notes qui ne sont pas dans les deux
prêts à continuer donc sacré civet donc
c'est pas vrai que vous avez dit
j'arrête à 37 ans à l'âge auquel me
rambo est mort on en a peut-être jamais
fini avec rimbaud quand on aime beaucoup
de films alors un autre notre revue ça
c'est publié ou à charleville à charles
vit alors un beau vivent ça c'est de lui
mais c'est plus lié par les amis de
rimbaud ça c'est le numéro la livraison
numéro 23
et puis vous avez publié la célèbre
biographie de rimbaud des mines star qui
est pas aux éditions flammarion il ya un
ou deux ans je crois c'est que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord vous le dis avec
certains aspects de cet inventaire et
enfin je signale ce livre c'était cd
tian bleu paru il ya quelques mois aux
presses universitaires de france rimbaud
système toll solaire ou trou noir
je terminerai avec un livre de cuisine
qui est l'oeuvre de patrice dard qui est
le cndd soirée familiale et familiale
et qui est un très très bon cuisinier la
nouvelle cuisine à l'ancienne donc de
patrice dard aux éditions solar avec une
préface de son papa san antonio
et puis alors préface d'henri vincenot
pour roger brun au bout du chemin et
comment on est en famille on est en
famille préfère alors place aux éditions
beaux chênes c'est l'histoire d'un
bourguignon ça c'est un beau vignes au
bout du chemin la vie à la mort et enfin
je n'ai rien pour vous êtes pas livre de
poche je le devais me faire jouer ou
signaler parce qu'on appellerait d'en
quête de filature quelque chose que je
trouve tout à fait remarquable aux
éditions ramsay le massacre de malin
c'est une énigme policière de dénis oui
terroriste qui sévit dans ce livre on
trouve tous les éléments de l'enquète
policière c'est à dire qu'il y a les
rapports de gendarmerie les les
photographies le remercier tout le
dossier criminel le plan des lieux etc
alors vous lisez tout ça comme comme un
flic me comme le commissaire et puis à
la fin il ya la réponse il faut trouver
la réponse
et la réponse est enfermé dans un petit
album à la fin qu'on n'ouvre que
lorsqu'on a tout lu c'est très astucieux
c'est très rigolo je pense à peut-être
venir s'y faire le mage de se vivre mais
on sait que donner des idées à san
antonio
alors hop nous habitons g et monsieur
mais si le j'ai vu un article dans la
presse je puis donc je suis ce que vous
avez interviewé un vous avez interrogé
un évêque un évêque monseigneur mamie
évêque de fribourg lausanne et genève
oui un éditeur suisse lui avait demandé
de 2 de ses mémoires enfin d'état tiab
louvain et cet éveil cliquer qui est un
lecteur à moi alors ce qui vous prouve
que je suis femme m
oui il est dans les bons endroits a
demandé ce que ça soit moi qui oublie
alors pour une fois je changeais drôle
en seniors mami a été un moment de
grande qualité
c'est dommage que j'aie par sully bhl je
l'aï envoyée je l'avais dos et
humiliations et c'était au dos et aux
éditions michel bien et bien pâle ben
marque ne cherchez plus et je te demande
pardon à mes gilles colliard mais c'est
l'éditeur ah bon alors du funky mais
sachant très bien parfait et bien vous
voilà vous entrez en entrée en grâce
j'avais un patient de d'y être déjà peu
je vais dire que monseigneur n'a fait
que confirmer la chose très bien et bien
merci à tous les cas de bonsoir à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
à
la semaine prochaine il me semble nous
aurons une bonne émission sur l'histoire
car sur le plateau à peu ce soir il y
aura vraiment quatre excellents
romancier puisqu'il s'agit d'alain
decaux de max gallo de pierre goubert et
de pierre nora l'émission aura pour
titre monument de la république
on nous proposait ainsi que le japonais
comme jean-philippe oui alors avec deux
des plus grands cinéastes japonais et
j'ai choisi le plus jappo celui qu'on
considère comme le plus japonais des
cinéastes à savoir aux yeux dont nous
voyons ce soir le voyage à tokyo et la
semaine prochaine nous donnerons en deux
parties parce que le film est
extrêmement long dans donne la version
complète
nous verrons les sept samouraïs de cure
sa voix qui lui est considéré comme le
plus intense internationale des
cinéastes japonais alors pour ce qui est
de aux yeux du voyage à tokyo
c'est un film de 1953 aux yeux est né en
1903 il est mort en 1963
donc c'est un film de sa pleine maturité
créatrice est un film qui a fait comme
tous ses autres films en donnant un soin
absolument méticuleuse jaloux à son
scénario en dessinant son film image par
image en faisant construire un décor
compte tenu des plantes qui était
absolument méditer prémédité par lui
avec lui tous ces techniciens et en
donnant et en prévoyant davance toutes
les mimiques et tous les gestes et tous
les regards de tous ces comédiens c'est
à dire que c'était quelqu'un qui ne
voulaient absolument rien laisser au
hasard parce qu'il vous ait une sorte de
culte à la nécessité culte ou la la
tristesse du renoncement joue avec un
bonheur paradoxal et où la plénitude de
de chaque instant et en joue
continuellement avec la vacuité profonde
de l'existence est un jeu permanent et
il c'est pour ça qu'il avait absolument
besoin de pousser jusqu'à ce degré de
préméditation et de désir volontaire de
parvenir à cet absolu là chacun de ces
plans chacune de ses mains
merci coach jean-philippe donc d'abord
le plus français des journalistes hervé
claude et ensuite le plus japonais
dessinée reste aux yeux